[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's amazing I can tell is like it is
like being there
hey I didn't see you there haha
welcome to jail scoff Asia a conference
for the whole family
you got to play with me it's gonna be a
lot of fun it was beautiful
[Music]
welcome to the of fortune those of you
those of you who have noticed my colos
has no voice those of you who have seen
me outside Singapore you know that I
speak with a pretentious British accent
but you are in my city now I'm speaking
English and this is how it sounds
let's go we need three players can I
have three volunteers to come up here
you know who you are that gentleman
right there
thank you that lady right there thank
you the lady right there come on up
thank you
I don't know how many of you grew up
watching
we are fortune if you're grabbing
Singapore it played on a channel called
channel 5 but if you would like to climb
in spine you can resize this morning
please line yourself up here so this is
we are fortune you can refer to the
screen for you audience will be looking
up there you can buy any consonants or
vowels have to be bought you tell him
your name shall enter your names as I
spoke through the rules and for the sake
of the audience so they can pick any
consonants if they learn on a point
vowels our four thousand points so if
you have no thousand points cannot buy
power if you let on undefiled
now-bankrupt
if you learn on not a number is fine you
keep your money
but the ton goes to the next player
I will give you cues so you don't worry
about the I'm just explaining if you hit
infinity or continue you spin again yeah
if you hit the pari sign instant win so
instead if anybody is 2x it just means
that whatever letter is what the more
points you have at a moment again we
will explain it but let's go okay so I
gonna give you a topic now
and that topic is kind of gives you an
idea of what the words our word is that
we're looking for it typically a phrase
or a sentence of sorts so let's see what
the first one is yes 2018 so I hope
you'll read up on the new versions of
JavaScript speaking it started with that
so the buzzer in front of you lights up
when you can spin meaning the first
press is you like kind of reach out and
the second press is to spin the faster
you press the two the faster the wheel
will spin the slower you do that this
will give it a try not twice can have
the music a little louder so now you
have a hundred so you can now choose a
letter constantly because vowels cost
about
[Music]
it's one routine fantastic
all right that means it's been again I'm
short two x Wow well
another constant
gee sorry next day of the sanika you
spin again alright oh nice it's wise
very good alright spin again Wow you may
also buy a vowel because bowels are
worth a thousand points and you clearly
have enough money yes you can use the
micro one Thank You umbrella of course
[Music]
like buy a vowel I - I feel like Wheel
of Fortune was a very North American
thing could be true in Singapore we had
a lot of North American company and toe
demon but our news mostly Spanish
English
it's alright Finnegan
[Music]
I always look close yeah
sorry can you repeat the letter you can
spin or you can solve I'm just trying to
like figure out what this might actually
be okay
[Music]
so just as I welcome is a free country
[Music]
what should I guess guys L nice I feel
like there should be a limitation on the
amount that I'm allowed to do this can I
buy a vowel yeah hey I'm gonna buy
another vowel yeah
e yep
[Music]
[Music]
I was crushing life it's not anymore
you can also choose the song if you are
feeling coffee done you can choose to
solve it if you know what it is
you might also as well at first get a
point I think you should yeah you may
give it an attempt so I'm guessing it's
promised prototype just go
I'm PI it magic kind of great well that
wasn't too hard was it
round 2 then remember a bankrupt still
makes you lose everything
I'm just going to take a nap here carry
on please carry on
the coffee is cos all right let's go
console all right Danica
[Music]
[Music]
let me do that again
very good next you can continue queuing
I clearly AM back in the system but it's
okay moving on
[Music]
very good I'll buy a vowel voice
activation go go
okay I'm going to ask the audience more
favor because this is Singapore if you
are not Singaporean you need to London
when they speak
the next time you spins your shell wanna
okay let's go thank you thank you keep
going keep going and these past name I
also know into go thank you you're very
enthusiastic a we ready are you showing
the foreigners they're Singaporeans not
into suggestions welcome
there's a timer it's okay T Open Sesame
[Music]
Yogesh a suggestion don't you answer no
[Music]
what should I guess and oh now it's
getting close
or Jinky want to open those oh you did
you give up on this I don't know what
the first word is yet can I have a D
well you can't buy it
tell you this pin afraid if you won
again deep can I solve it now okay
undefined is not a function
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow okay it's getting closer
Robin now you're leading you wanna say
something about yourself really quick
I'm just trying to be a good game show
host here where you from
what I'm originally from Canada but I
live in Singapore I moved here last
month Walmart one more welcome come on
thank you all right
that's very good in you I'm originally
from Switzerland I came here in January
to you
where are my Singaporeans why all I did
we're gonna do one more round
okay get started a bit later so we can
finish a bit later and the topic of that
round if he is boring we do another one
[Music]
all right counting us arts 1000 it's
because you don't use the microphone
observe
[Music]
500t nice all at once
I'm tired every letter is what eleven
thousand points gay friends serious
pressure
what should I guess make your choice
y'see no there's a timer there's a pile
of H okay can I buy a vowel
plenty buy all of them I don't know I
don't want to buy any vowels with the
33,000 oh okay stay on the bot let's go
can I buy another vowel sure you can buy
all of them
[Music]
v/o my most part us I hope you boys why
us Oh what could it be now how do you
feel
can I buy another vowel yeah I let's go
that's a tough one
no spoilers no spoilers excuse me it is
a competitive a devil are you doing no
crisis for you should I risk another
spin and lose everything I think I think
okay I'm gonna stop cheating
there's a timer yo D yo u DD dog hasn't
doggy already how to exit the vim editor
[Applause]
[Music]
okay clearly she has absorbed a lot I
don't know why but and then you're still
going hello Sam oh I don't know very
sporting thank you Oh
[Music]
thank you sorry gonna give the word for
Speaker of the day and get the
professional host in now Martin is our
host to today together with which in so
you won't hear my voice for for a while
at least
and so please give it up for aging and
Martin will drive through this today and
will make this whole program
[Applause]